wenn sie jetzt denken ja sicherlich
diese grünwald freitags kommen die diese
sendung die sich ja lustig ohne ende
aber so direkt lernen durch man nichts
dabei das ist ein umstand den wir jetzt
sehr schnell ändern werden meine damen
und herren immer sehr lehrreich aber
auch sehr charmant die bezaubernde
claudia pichler
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich gespannt er zu jetzt
interessant oder was hast du uns
mitgebracht heute ja günter ewertz sind
wie du persönlich zu dem thema esoterik
stößt aber mir geht's so wenig dies her
familie bis zum modernen oder weiß dass
bei uns in bayern eigentlich euro geben
also mir keiner dort ist ab wetten dass
ist so heilung durch gebet quasi also
das kennst du vielleicht auf und der
behandlung von warzen also traditionell
werden bei uns warten ja besprochen und
zwar macht man das mit so einem
sprüchlein es geht also schwarze weiche
wright auf einer leiche auf dem fluss
der zeit davon und so ist die waffen für
die chance bei mir über das kinder mehr
warum sie sagt machen aber dann noch mit
der kurze nebenwirkungen kinder schon
mehr auftreten aber es gibt da nur
drastische methoden um die warzen
loszuwerden kunst zum beispiel ein
heubad die zwiebeln ema streiks den sie
über die warten und dann vergräbt den
zweifel bei vollmond im garten oder zu
mitternacht lässt du das oder schnecken
über die warzen grüner oder du kannst ja
gern mein sohn war mariner trick
anything oder als letzte lösung der
künstler an großvater nach dem genuss
von simao weißbier einfach über die
warzen drüber bieten lassen
also warum war schnell ein schmarrn aber
immer song so frieder im stau wenn jetzt
mal sagt sie plötzlich gestorben ist
oder die kur hardcore milli mehr geben
dann hast du eben die up dad und dort
dann käufer mit zu sprechen also das
waren wir so zauberformeln welche genau
das kann jetzt leider doch nicht auf
sondern weil die haben wir so eine kraft
du hast das kann man nicht einfach
zwingst der gaudi sonko pa verantwortung
könnte er sie nicht wir du reagieren
daten noch er sowieso anspruch und du
fängst du spontan zum keimen
es war geschafft aber um diesen spruch
praktisch die diese formel irgendwie
abzufangen kommt mir ein großvater war
dann einfach über mich drüber bist oder
aber diese alternativen heilmethoden
einheit an relativ wichtig also nicht
nur für menschen sondern immer immer nur
für tiere man spricht nur halten immer
vom ab better sondern vom
tierheilpraktiker also ein bissel druck
wohnt das sowas wie pferde werden
akupunktiert oder so aber es geht ja bis
in den kleinen tierbereich also hund
katz kanaren karnickel koi karpfen
völlig wurscht du kannst alles behandeln
und wenn der rauhaardackel zum beispiel
und der bindungsängste leidet ja dann
probiert man es einmal mit einer
familienaufstellung
das ist gerade noch und wie man beim
heilpraktiker ist da sagt mir der hat ja
auch den großen erfolg weiß ich würde
einfach zuwendet und war mit der recht
lange und so aber jetzt soll der
schäferhund langweilt sich dort zu tode
oder
brauchst du wirklich ein profi der das
macht und die müssen echt sein es gibt
sogar die tierheilpraktiker also ich
habe mit eigenen augen max ingwer ordner
ganz professionell so eine
fußreflexzonenmassage durchgeführt hat
bei einem meerschweinchen gegen
blähungen und es hat funktioniert ja
das ist so jetzt ist ja bei einem
goldhamster vor mir habe ist einmal mit
akupunktur probiert ich hoffe bloß
stricken oder
ist möglich ich hab doch erklärungen
hatte dann im kampf
gegen überlassen meinte prof absolut ja
mensch heimatlos kehren also wirklich
immer eine große freude wiens top ist
und
claudia ziegler
[Musik]